[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 96 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
hi I'm Francis Campo and I'm here with
my colleague back Mendel hey Mark how
are you doing I am well France ask how
are you doing currently in the City of
Austin actually nice you're in the City
of Austin I'm in San Francisco and
you're wearing a beautiful ladies is
gender neutral t-shirt I saw that on
Twitter and it's a beautiful t-shirt I
am wearing that t-shirt it's my favorite
ladies t-shirt I was gonna ask how many
you have but you know that's up to you
so I will not judge anyway well the
ladies so oh my all my t-shirts are
ladies t-shirts true that's a very good
point it's a very good t-shirt I reckon
anyway we'll have a picture on the show
notes maybe not or just follow me on
Twitter yeah so we today we're gonna be
talking about something quite cool that
actually I did not know anything about
it is aveer and it's a hybrid file
system for the clouds with an S I'd say
yeah we have both Dave and Scott joining
us on the show
I want Googler one from aveer basically
talking about how you can build hybrid
file systems that span both on-prem and
the cloud it's actually really really
cool yeah very very interesting episode
and after that we'll have a question of
the week and the question of the week is
okay I've heard that Google cloud
containing builder it's cool how do I
get started
like is there some tutorial that I could
go through and the answer is actually
yes
and we'll answer that later but before
that we have our cool things of the week
yes and we have a lot of them actually
I'm going to start with the first one
which is something really cool so we
have a new region in South America and
it is in Sao Paulo so if you're in
Brazil congratulations because now you
have a very very close to you region and
it is really cool because it's gonna be
a big thing to celebrate during the
Google cloud summit in Sao Paulo which
if I'm not mistaken is next month are
you gonna be there no I will not be
there probably not because I have other
plans all the trips but according to
this is November 8th in 9th
so if you have not registered try to
find it actually we'll have a link on
the show notes to a registration form
but otherwise just fine Google Cloud Sam
it's Apollo awesome
the second one is one of those things
that I just know for how long people
have been like when you're gonna have
this when you're gonna have this when
you're gonna have this and so now we
have ipv6 on our global load balancing
it is now GA you can either nuts with
all your ipv6 needs so global load
balancer is our load balancer that spans
globe which is awesome so now you can do
load balancing for HTTP proxy to proxy
all the good things pretty excited now
that we can finally do all that stuff
cool because ipv4 we're running out of
ipv4 addresses vizier right is at the
same time as the year of the linux on
the desktop or is it a different year
every year is your full UNIX desktop
exactly and it's every year we ran out
of ipv4 so okay and the next one is
about natural language API and it is
pretty interesting cos is basically the
one that allows you to extract knowledge
from text basically I think it's a
decent way of putting it yeah and what
it's doing now it's actually able to
classify the context of the text so if
you are looking for something and you
have the word lobster right Lobster when
you're talking about Blatz lobster and
potatoes
that's probably cooking but if you talk
about Lobster it may be I don't know
rocks and stuff like that maybe you're
actually talking about biology so this
new feature would allows you to do is to
extract that context out of the
information which is something very
useful yeah it's really cool we've
actually got two articles we're going to
talk about here one of which just sort
of goes through the new things so it's
got classifying content it also has more
sentiment analysis on entities you can
get some cool ideas about the idea of
what sort of tone people might be using
but the second article actually has
example code in it so you can go through
and see like results from Jason and how
you can interact directly with the API
so we'll have both of those linked in
the show notes I really like the example
for the context detection is something
that I will not be able to reply because
I have no idea of
American sports but says Rafael Montero
shines in Mets victory over the Reds I
have no idea what that means that's team
sports baseball so it is good it's a
it's an API that is more useful than
myself which is always good awesome
and so finally last one Google Cloud
Data prep is now a public beta so you
may have seen the announcement back in
March where we on sit as a private beta
but basically it is a visual way that
you can look at data stores and and big
data sets so that you may need to clean
up or modify or basically be able to
look at and do transformations on but
doesn't necessarily require a programmer
interface so basically for analysts
things like that who want to be able to
do it directly through a UI it actually
looks really cool yeah isn't this what
we saw as a solution at some point to
show really fancy way of showing billing
information thing is based on these and
bigquery I think you're talking about
data studio which is the visualization I
keep on mixing those two and if you feel
like maybe we should have someone from
those teams come explain that
if you're a product manager or an
engineer from cloud data prep or data
studio please come talk to us yes we
would love to have you on the show
cool so that was all of the cool things
of the week or actually the cool things
of the week that we had time to cover
yep and I think it's time to go and talk
to her friends from actually friends
from Revere in Google Dave Eliot
Enschede sonic sounds good let's go do
that today I am very excited to have
Dave Elliott developer advocate for
cloud platform at Google as well as
Scott Josh ranek who is the director of
cloud products at avear systems thank
you both for joining us how are you
doing today Scott doing great thanks for
having us and how you doing today Dave
fantastic excellent well thank you so
much for joining us today have a chat
about of your systems the stuff that you
build on top of GCP some the products
you have and how they came about but
before we get into that I wanted you
tell listeners a little bit about
yourselves Dave why don't you go first
sure so I'm a developer advocate here
with cloud platform been with Google for
about four years my background is
storage and networking and I spend most
of my time now working with companies in
particular enterprises that are looking
to adopt cloud and you know in
particular looking at adopting cloud and
storage solutions listen Scott why don't
you tell us about yourself hi so yeah
I'm the director of product management
it appear specifically for our cloud
products and our software roadmap I've
got a varied background in IT as well as
telecom software products and most
recently at aveer systems with storage
cool so now that we know who you are
let's look a little bit about aveer what
is fe air and what do you do so there's
around nine years old eight nine years
old and you know when we originally
started the prada the the product line
and the company it was to address
performance and latency issues with
network attached storage so if you were
let's say you were creating a movie and
you wanted that movie to be rendered in
a certain period of time and you created
a render farm and you have whatever a
thousand servers sitting there
well the servers are gonna beat the crap
out of your network attached storage
it's inevitable especially back then
because flash was still really expensive
and hard to really come by for those
solutions over time we evolved our
solution off of our you know datacenter
product and started adopting cloud
technologies specifically if you wanted
to create for example render farm in the
cloud and you wanted to work it straight
that and run that against some data
that's sitting wherever a veer provides
the technology the caching technology
and data access to all the technology
for that but we also support abstracting
a POSIX file system on top of Google
Cloud Storage so if you have
applications that you want to run and
you want to put all the data up in the
cloud but you really need those POSIX
bits and you need to manage it as you
did before appear it gives you that
continuity so is this just a cloud
solution is this something you can run
on Prem like where does this thing
actually sit great question so it can be
both we have customer
today very large studios in Hollywood
that do a lot of rendering and it's all
on premise but we have other customers
in that space who have started to break
up their data center clusters and are
looking at you know running in GCP a lot
of the reason that they want to do that
is it's far more flexible they don't
have to own so much hardware on Prem
especially like a lot of these guys have
sort of capped out as to how much they
really want to put in a data center so
having GCP especially being able to take
their existing workflows and putting
them up there is a real advantage so we
run both on Prem and we ported our
appliance into GCE instances that can
run in GCE adjacent to whatever workload
that you're running cool it sounds like
it's either unpromoted is that the case
that's right we're both you can plug
them in both we're like the Swiss Army
knife of data access basically when it
comes to that kind of thing yeah that's
a part of the beauty of what they offer
and how they help our customers approach
and a sort realized hybrid cloud right
if you think of the your compute
instances in the cloud your compute
instances on Prem your storage in the
cloud say with GCS and your storage on
Prem what a veer helps companies do is
sort of move between those four entities
those those four you know types of
computing storage we say that we are
able to have storage that is distributed
in between the cloud and on-premise does
that mean that you connected through a
VPN does everything need to be in the
same network how does this work yeah
it's a great question so if I were a
truly a developer in our team I would
say it depends and it depends on all the
variables right so typical use case is
going to be we're gonna recommend that
you're using a gigabit per second link
over the network because a lot of our
customer base they're not doing really
small-scale stuff they're doing some
pretty serious uploading and processing
of data so laws of physics you want to
make sure that that day together gets
there as quickly as you can
VPN over the Internet
is a little tricky because we're then at
the mercy of whatever Layton sees the
internet provides one of the things that
our product really strives to do is you
know be a killer of latency when it
comes to workloads so for running a
thousand VMs in GCE I can't afford to
have latency bogging down the job and so
we typically want to have a link behind
us that is sufficient enough to get as
much data into our layer as we can oh
and you also asked about network so like
from a GCE perspective you're gonna run
the vir cluster and we only run
clustered you're gonna run that in a sub
network not a classic sub Network but a
regular sub Network in GCE with your
with your compute nodes and does a veer
like encrypt the traffic through or how
does what is the security side of things
here well so it's twofold one if you're
using us as a data access layer with
your nas back on Prem so that's so
that's one of the typical use cases as I
may have a net app or a nice align
environment and I just need to get to
some subset of that data we're gonna
tell you and we have written this all up
in best practices that you're gonna want
to secure your link between your data
center and the Google Network and it
wouldn't matter if you were just using
us or if you were using any of the
Google services that require that kind
of interaction and we don't encrypt that
we would expect that to be encrypted but
since we also can use GCS as backing
storage which is kind of an interesting
twist we basically treat GCS as block we
become the navs for that
that's all SSL encrypted as well as the
data being encrypted at rest cool so
here are the buckets we are firm
believers in open source so I'd like to
know is these open source is there
something that we can check out the code
and stuff open source being a vendor
such a struggle so you know look I'll
tell you what we did do with one of the
things about our product since is
clustered you know the court the court
code itself is proprietary it's it's
because it's highly tuned for caching we
do a lot of complex read ahead and right
behind I always kind of liken it to like
putting rocks in a raging river and
trying to steer the data or steer the
water in a certain way it's very
difficult to do and you never know
what's
happened downstream so that's really
complicated stuff but to manage and set
up the cluster especially if you're a
developer and you're looking to create
like an orchestration pipeline we
created a Python library that we've put
up in github we'll give you the URL to
it it's no problem and as long as you're
able to access our image which is simple
as reaching out to a veer and asking us
we can grant you evaluation access to
the to the code and this Python library
you got you can pick your poison you can
either import it into your Python logic
that's fine and create clusters of our
product pointing at your network
attached storage back on Prem as long as
you have the IP address of the export
you don't even have to this can all be
done very easily and we also created a
wrapper Python for that so basically
with one line you can set up the entire
cluster fully configured ready to go I
will say from from a Google perspective
you have some options if you're if
you're looking at file services you
could use our single node filer there's
some limitations actually a fair number
of limitations on that you could also we
support cluster so if you can't really
are looking for an open source a
solution that some of the challenges
there are really around configuration
management of large clusters or you can
use a commercial partner veer is you
know our go-to partner for these file
services great we actually discussed on
episode let me freshen episode 40 that's
really long time ago
we interviewed audio effects and they
were talking about how they were using
cluster efest would you say that I fear
is kind of like more manage and already
to use version of cluster offense what
are the differences oh yeah so I'm gonna
make it hypothetical even though what
I'm saying is directly related to a
customer okay okay so we have a customer
there in the render space they built
with Gluster the reason they did it
which is a reason a lot of folks do it
is that well first of all you know if
you're a developer and you're good at
what you do you just want to get to what
you need and move on and that's one of
the advantages of open source like go
get cluster code and go run it and I'm
done but it's never as simple as that
when you start to introduce it into a
complex environment like a
environment where latency is an issue
long-term maintenance is his issue
you're getting chased by angry artists
and angry studio people that want you
know the latest seen rendered now and
there's a there's an issue with Gluster
open source that you can't figure out so
you know you have to take an ownership
of a lot of stuff there the question
that I always put back and this'll sound
salesy for the developers I apologize
I'm not in sales yes
is that your core business is storage
and performance of storage your core
business
no its rendering movies so the faster
you can render a movie whether you're
using commercial products open source or
combination of it the better off for the
company so I would say where we're
different is first of all you can have a
cluster of our product up and running in
about you know 8 9 minutes using that
Python code ready to go serving ops you
can plug-in storage from on-prem which
was cluster you really kind of can't do
that you can have a mount point but
you're gonna be at the mercy of whatever
the latencies are of that link and then
ultimately with Gluster you know is it a
che are you gonna have redundant storage
and then your costs are gonna go up from
what you think is gonna be relatively
inexpensive solution once you start
trying to scale it with 500 600 VMs
you're quickly gonna find that cluster
just can't keep up and you kind of need
something either you're gonna have to
you know build on top of cluster your
own custom environment which again puts
you in a different business or you look
for a commercial provider cool so let's
let's swing back around to sort of
developer experience and how that works
so I'm kind of curious as well so you
say this is a POSIX file system so sort
of two questions one so this essentially
means that I can interact with this once
it's all mounted and set up basically
like a local file system and then you'll
handle all the latency and the other
question I'll tack on to that is Dizzy's
work in both directions can I go from
cloud to Prem and then Prem to cloud
like how does that work absolutely so to
answer your first question so from a
developer perspective you know you have
Google cloud platform with a lot of
fantastic technologies like all the
machine learning intents are flow and
the micro-services capabilities that's
all exciting and it's
sort of like you're you're starting to
think about how can I develop with all
these new tools and what value can I
Drive in the company for you know to
with these new tools and that's great
and that's your next cycle that's what
you're building towards but then you
have this whole host of applications
today and I'm gonna exclude database
applications just because if I were
using a relational database I'd go put
it up in Google's relational database
product and be done with it
just to make my life simpler but let's
just think about file based applications
that you have so let's say their
business you know mission critical can't
really tear them down and we offer them
there are six seven years old and
they've just been working do you really
want to break that well you know why do
that just go run it up in Google run it
on some VMs or some containers and we
just present a mount point so you just
mount that export and and you're ready
to go that's the easiest way to look at
it from a developer's perspective is do
I want to spend time rewriting a lot of
things that I don't need to and
therefore delay my entry into cloud
because of all of that or do I want to
just slam them up there into the cloud
use the exports from the aveer and then
I can go work on these other new and
interesting things while that stuff's
just doing what it used to do and to the
second question which is can I go in
both directions thanks for reminding
about second question which I tell you
yeah so you know if you let's say you're
using our physical appliance what are
the use cases with our product
especially in life sciences like all the
genetic sequencing companies they're
creating they're creating amazing
amounts of data petabytes of data they
got to put it somewhere and so they're
all looking at putting it up into the
places like Google Cloud Storage but the
problem that they all run into
especially in that particular space is
all their pipeline applications
everything they used to do alignment and
and variant analysis and everything
they're all file based people are
rewriting some of them but it's the same
problem again is that my day job do I
have time to stop people using the
classic tool to get this new tool and
then I have to spend six months
debugging it or can I just put the stuff
up there and so vir will allow you to
put it into Google Cloud storage but
we put it air in a way that allows you
to see it as posix and when I say posix
it means a directory structure the
standard POSIX bits and we also do it in
a sharded way so that you don't have to
worry about multi-part gets and puts or
having to get the entire file out of
Google and pay the egress charge cool so
I don't know if it's my jet lag or it
just like I missed something but I'm
curious about where do you actually
store this information is it stored in
GC instances Soren Cloud Storage and
persistent disks where does this
information actually live at the end it
is not your jet lag it's a completely
legitimate question everybody asks us so
one of the things to think of us as and
when people ask us what we really do I
say we we basically facilitate access to
data and we do it at a high performance
level all right the data itself resides
on your nas it resides in your GCS
bucket the only data that resides on a V
R is any data that has been requested by
clients for the latest job so it's
basically a cache we also leverage local
SSD technology in Google which by the
way I mean Google's local SSD facility
is fantastic we get great performance
out of it we also do support the
persistent SSDs but you get an upper
bound of throughput on the persistent
SSDs so if we want to max out
performance we use local but again it's
only transient data it goes away when
you're done yeah also I'll say you know
of your systems these are file system
experts and the caching algorithms that
they've developed you know over their
seven years are unbelievable Best of
Breed or best around so you know it's a
it's a scenario of you know because
they've got these these these fantastic
caching algorithms that makes latency
and performance just that much better
cool so my next question is since mark
was asking about the directions of the
mappings and live I can basically get
like Google Cloud storage as POSIX
systems on my instance can I also map
the same folders multi into multiple
instances like it's multi read multi
right yes is a veer a good way of
communicating across many different
machines or is it more a place where you
basically just use it to store stuff
that is being used by one single worker
good question the sweet spot use case if
you think about it is I'm gonna run a
render farm I'm gonna run a post
sequencing genomic analysis to like cure
some disease I'm going to do a Monte
Carlo simulation and financial services
so I can squeeze more money out of my
fund those are all things that run
thousands of machines and typically
those machines going to come up and
they're gonna all read some sort of
common set of data and that is
tailor-made for caching so our where we
really shine in terms of technologies if
you have an HPC cluster or a compute
environment and you've got a lot of
nodes demanding data from some storage
that is simply not going to be able to
keep up with it we do support writing
the data out so you can do your render
and then write out your your results and
we cache those rights as well and that
gives you performance on that side of it
from the sort of single client accessing
a folder kind of use case that you
mentioned that's really like the the
domain of something like a single node I
mean it just depends on on how you're
gonna use that particular technology
it's not that we can't support a single
client doing and it's just that we're
really built for the high performance
space just to dig a little bit deeper
let's imagine that we have as you were
saying a lot of workers that are
actually really in the same piece of
data and then somehow there's another
worker that updates that what you're
saying is that you're going to manage
the cache invalidation across all of the
places where that information might have
been cached and that will be transparent
to the user yeah and and just to be
clear that's within one of our clusters
so a cluster can be three nodes and that
three node cluster can service I don't
know 501 high mem fours or high my mate
so it's not a small environment but you
can run 20 nodes 23 knows 24 nodes of
our system and
is a tremendously large scale operation
that you'd be running there 65 70,000
cores but every right gets cached and
every read gives cash for all the
clients and the rights are always
protected so if somebody writes
something and somebody else wants to
read it they're gonna read the latest if
somebody tries to write on that right
then that that'll all be tracked and
modified and updated quick accordingly
cool I have no idea what the answer to
this questions gonna be Ben I'm curious
so if we're big fans of kubernetes and
it's been a hot topic about how to store
our data inside particularly containers
and kubernetes
is there a plug-in or basically a way
for using a vir technology to do like
persistent volume claims or basically
store lots of data so you can do like
HPC workloads on kubernetes yeah I mean
so I looked into this I also looked into
Hadoop right and if you're not just the
diverge for one second from kubernetes
you're using Hadoop and you're not
married to HBase and other like H query
as part of your sort of tool chain and
you'd be able to use your Hadoop job as
a file based job you can actually do
something I call hybrid a dupe which is
basically run a Hadoop cluster in GCE
you severe access layer against your net
app on kubernetes I mean I'm a little
torn because in terms of kubernetes
appear if you have a tiny small data
slice and you're very sophisticated
developer and you're able to place that
little slice of data just just so in
each container you know you know that's
really fine I mean you can go ahead and
use that but if you want you can use
kubernetes containers with an export
within NFS export Mountain point so
there's no reason why you couldn't bring
up lots of containers pointing at a
export and consume the data from that
export just as you so that's actually
you hit the hit the lead there a little
so you also not only got your own sort
of maybe fuse technology or something
like that but you expose it as something
like NFS or other standard sort of file
mounting solutions so that if you have
existing tools it's super easy to just
get those up and running with a veer
yeah actually you just raised a critical
point to this is not fuse so fuse is a
little tricky because it's user space
it's got an upper bounded performance if
you just need to do some basic stuff
with fuse I'm never gonna argue against
it but it's it's not really meant for
high-performance sophisticated workloads
it is you know the stuff we wrote is
grounded in very very fundamental code
that I you know unless we all mutually
assign some NDA I can't really say what
it is but we never know it's yeah it
sounded like you have like an NFS mount
basically standard file sharing type
protocols seem to be supported by there
yeah so the front end of our product
basically presents NFS or sips and if
you're using GCSE object as the backing
storage for it it can actually support
multi protocol out the front and it
integrates with Active Directory and
everything else so so yeah mark maybe we
did bury the lead a little bit on there
really the two use cases we we really
talked about with the vir one assist
this killer of latency because they've
got the great caching algorithms but the
second is is really that translation
layer right for for folks who who want
to use those those file based services
you know rely on NFS or SMB to be able
to begin to move to to our cloud and
just as a side note some small render
farms and studios their their workflows
are based on SMB sifts and so that you
know we give them that luxury of using
that as well cool so now here's a little
bit about whether you can talk about
some of your customers or cool use cases
that you've seen what kind of use cases
we mentioned rendering what are the
things you've seen that were powered by
a vir sure so taking it along the same
line as anybody with a lot of need to
read a lot of common data at a low
latency we have a lot of interesting use
cases in you know I always say like
Hollywood health and hedge funds for
some reason those are really smooth mods
for us but we also work in the oil and
gas space so you got a lot of geologic
analysis surveys that are very read
intensive you'll hear me emphasize read
but just so that I'm clear we also have
ingest use cases so
for example somebody I cannot possibly
name nor ever will name somewhere in the
eastern part of this country takes a lot
of pictures and those pictures are being
stored in very deep storage and that
ingest has to happen at a certain high
rate and we're talking about larger
files here so that it's clear and so you
know especially on our physical product
we do a lot of right caching and we have
NVRAM cards built into our hardware so
we're able to more quickly ingest and
acknowledge those those rights quickly
and and that's another important point
from a developer's perspective if you
have a pipeline that depends on
receiving an ACK from the protocol level
a fear does the ack immediately after
receiving the write and caches that
right across partners so let's see video
ingest transcoding of video rendering
farms bioinformatics name it I mean
pharmaceutical biological analysis with
those are all places that we play and we
also sell to colleges right and the
combination of of being able to leverage
things like on the compute side
preemptable VMS the the the cost of you
know spinning up thousands of cores and
using them for rendering or for you know
hedge fund trading or things like that
you know simulations it really is a game
changer that really is you know I would
say probably the single biggest you know
killer use case it's that it's that that
the latency killer and enabling GCE
compute instances that are you know
Wireless wildly scalable you know highly
available and super super low cost
that's where it becomes you know super
super interesting cool so we're kind of
running out of time but I had one last
question which is what's the best way to
get started www.iberia.com you can
always reach out to me my contact
information is probably posted and I can
put
yeah and I could put you in touch with
the right folks but it's it's really not
that difficult to get started with the
cluster and you can go out to github
today and get the the Python library and
and have a look at what we're doing and
what we base it on and that's that's the
easiest way and is there anything we
haven't managed to cover you wanna plug
any events or any special stuff that you
think we our listeners should know about
of here you know probably the next place
that we're going to be is at the Google
summit on September 27th in Chicago I
will actually be taking on booth duty so
feel free to stop by the booth and we
can certainly talk and and I'll just add
that the Vere systems actually was the
GCP technology partner of the year a
couple of years ago and we have ongoing
engineering alignment so you'll see
better and better and better solutions
with the two of us as we as we go
forward
that was your wink and nudge right
awesome
well thank you so much to both they even
stopped for taking the time today to
talk about about Xavier and all the cool
things people are building with it thank
you guys yeah thank you thanks so much
again to both Dave and Scott for such an
interesting interview I hope it was fair
for me to ask about lesser FS but I feel
like it is really interesting that
there's so many different options to
provide file systems that are over the
cloud plus like your own computers and
and it's you know it's important to be
to be able to make a difference and you
know a lot the answer yeah no super
super interesting stuff same thing again
like being able to scale both your
compute and your storage across on-prem
and cloud I think is very impressive and
also highly useful for a bunch of
workloads yeah and I'm gonna do a
shameless plug for ourselves and say
that if you want to learn a little bit
more about similar use cases we
interviewed brother effects
she's the visual effects studio that
does really fancy things among other
things they do things for Game of
Thrones and Deadpool and stuff and they
talked a little bit about how they use
the cloud plus their premise and they do
use glass or FS they do not use a
but it is still very interesting because
if you want to check that out it was
episode 40 long time ago that was in
2016
awesome yeah definitely check that out
that was a great episode so why do I get
stuck into our question of the week you
set things up nicely but I know you have
good answers so we were talking about
container builder basically I want to
build some stuff in the cloud using
container builder but I don't know I
thinking about it like where do I get
started what can I do to learn more
about this thing it seems really cool
yep so the question was really cook is
the question actually comes from someone
yesterday at the go meetup that took
place in the docker office here in San
Francisco yes and they were talking
about the newest features of docker and
one of the cool things that are coming
but still not in the stable release is
multistage builders and multistage
builders are super cool because they
allow you to basically do the typical
things we do them with a make file which
is you you use a container with all of
your compilers and all the developing
tools and then out of that you generate
a binary that then you put in a
different container and normally we used
to double the make file at least I'm
sure that you mark to make well yes yes
for sure so now you can do that with
just one docker file which is very
useful and they asked me to say so how
do you use this like the you upgrade to
the latest version and my answer was
like actually no actually you can use
this directly on container builder which
is super cool because first of all you
don't make your machine work too much
because the building process itself will
happen in the cloud but also you get the
newest features of docker before they're
actually unstable because they basically
peak the best features in order to have
them there and so you can experiment
with them which is really cool so the
question after that was ok cool how do I
use this right how they get started and
of course the first answer is read the
docs read the manual and we have a link
to the docs but even a mistaken is
cloud.google.com slash container -
builder but anyway we'll have a link in
the show notes the second thing that you
can do and it's the second shameless
plug of the episode is that we actually
did an episode with Christopher sensor
and David bender a which is which our
product manager and one of the
one of the software engineers in the
container builder team where they told
us everything about containers builder
and that was on episode 79 now the thing
I did not know that I discovered because
someone sent it to me via Twitter was
that our dear friend and co-worker Cara
Morgan has a series on YouTube our
container builder and there's two videos
already and they're really good the
first one is basically an intro to
container builder plus how to do cloud
rolling updates directly for container
builder which is super useful and the
second one is on how to use not
multi-stage pills but multi-step builds
which is not exactly the same thing yeah
it's not exactly the same thing it's
basically more like when you wanted to
go vet and go test and then go build and
then send that to a container and then
that container should be deployed
somewhere else right like those are
multiple steps that are not necessarily
related to talker yep multistage build
is inside of a docker file so not
completely the same but very related
nuts now I really I love container
builder for what for a long time I was
kind of confused about it I thought it
was a thing to build containers but then
I realized it is actually a thing that
builds things with containers yeah which
is a flippin mental thought yet slightly
ambiguous naming yes yes but great
product nonetheless excellent all right
before we wrap out Franceschi you going
anywhere doing anything interesting is
there a just for Frank we should know
about so by the time this comes out
there will be a chess or funk that will
come out on the 25th and also on that
day I will be flying to Chicago because
on the 27th I will be speaking at GLAAD
summit Chicago and I'll be presenting
about tensorflow
we're excited about that yeah and after
that as I said before there's gonna be a
bunch of events there'll be velocity
London of the cloud summit in Paris and
I'll be numbed
all of that the same day basically I'll
be there from basically October 17th to
20th there's gonna be four days where
I'm gonna be speaking every single day
in a different City that's fun yeah what
about you when this episode comes out I
will be actually actually on a plane
going to st. Louis for
strange loop so I'll be hanging out
there if anyone else is also going also
say hi please come up and say hello then
in October I will also be going over to
Australia as you've just got back I will
be speaking at dev fest Melbourne I will
be speaking at G cap asia-pacific I'll
be hanging out at PAX I've been hanging
out at unite I do have some days free so
if any people who are listening and from
Melbourne and they want to get together
and talk about cloud or games or games
in cloud or any of that sort of stuff
please feel free to reach out pick me I
would be more than happy to hang out
with you have a coffee cool and in
Melbourne things yeah I know that Google
developer group cloud in Melbourne will
be happy to have you but I will let them
find you I think it's it's been a while
that we have not done this so why don't
we remain our dear listeners how to get
in touch with us so they can send this
cool things of the week or questions of
the week or just like random rant or
saying that they love us and we're
amazing also we accept that kind of
critic yeah sounds good you can ask the
questions I'll fill in the [ __ ] yeah cos
I yeah this like I will never get it
ever so let's start with twitter at
@anjghie TV podcast we are also in
Google Plus at plus GCP podcast we do
have a web page it's GCP podcast calm or
cloud.google.com slash podcast and we
also have an email hello at GCP podcast
calm we are on reddit slash are slash
GCP podcast and last but not least we
run slack at the hatch podcast channel
in bit Dudley slash gtp - slack and
someone mentioned at some point we are
the only podcast that doesn't say please
rate us on iTunes or subscribe or
whatever so please do that - yeah please
subscribe yeah yeah subscribe and leave
like good reviews and stuff
apparently it's important so yeah please
do it yes please like subscribe and
stuff I don't know I feel kind of weird
saying that but anyway all of you please
do the nice thing yeah there you go all
right friends awesome thank you once
again for another episode thank you Mark
and thank you all for listening and
we'll see you all next week
[Music]